no matter how far you go cannot escape
his face hi I'm Mike single from FX
guide.com four-wide looking at the tech
at the making of the creatures of
Hercules in a film called Hercules the
audience expects something well amazing
feats mythical creatures after all the
legends of the Greek gods are
fundamental to our cultural storytelling
in this new film director Brett Ratner
shows us those mythical creatures and
the truths behind the visual effects
house double- under the direction of
overall VFX John Bruno had to walk the
line between man and myth to bring to
life those Herculean legendary 12 labors
but as a series of exaggerated stories
now the problem with making something
exaggerated and false even to the film's
own logic is that you have to make it
still seem real and believable after all
in the film these myths are not meant to
be funny just improbable even though
they had to produce three-headed dogs
giant boars and multi-headed serpents
the DNA team had to make these shots
seem credible the team wanted to explore
all of this work while they were still
filming the team started by shooting as
much as they could in the original
plates this sometimes meant having
stuntmen run up trees or immersing the
rock Dwayne Johnson in swamps or even
pulling rubber heads out of water on
wires with great reference and great
plate photography the team would then
realize these fully digital characters
the giant lion was particularly
challenging requiring complex fur and
hair simulation that both illustrated
the creatures size and also gave a
frightening drama to the show
for this Deena used their third ball
tool developed just a year or so ago
this is actually the first ever image
that had rendered fur ball is a fully
GPU based solution that can preview the
fur in record time without this tool the
team wouldn't be able to move at the
pace they did for example this sequence
was all but finished while first unit
was still shooting the film the fur ball
GPU rendering provides exactly the speed
and final image quality that's needed
and it's a used on almost all of the
creature shots the effects team went
back on set with several creature shots
including this near final of the lion
leaping as you can imagine it's very
reassuring for the cast and the crew
like to see shots like this while
they're still working it gives
confidence and most importantly it
allows the director time to properly
integrate the shots into the story
especially when they move into editing
gone are the days of judging a film's
pace and edit while having only stand-in
stills making VFX actually much more
part of the production and much less of
a post afterthought well don't forget
subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm Mike Seymour for wide now
tell me
ah
you